this is life pot eight requesting
immediate assistance we've touched down
too close to the crash site and
radiation levels are too high to
disembark according to the manifest
lifepods four through seven should be
equipped with radiation suits if anyone
can hear this please retrieve the suits
and converge on our position for evac
coordinates are attached this message
will now repeat oh [ __ ] I have a mission
holy hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica sorry for the cold open there
but apparently life pod eight is in
trouble I've never actually seen that
before I need to find life pods five
through seven why would only some of the
life pods have the necessary equipment
to be able to do that radiation suits I
have no idea why that is but I suppose
what I could do is I could bring these
nutrient blocks with me in a flare and
some tie turning them I don't need this
much titanium I suppose I can another
one automated distress signal from
Aurora life pod seven coordinates are
attached
well there's seven in there's eight oh
my god don't die I think they're gonna
die it's night I did not know it was
nigh I have a flashlight
look at the beautiful underwater sea
that is the nightmare of my life okay so
supposedly I hate that have I mentioned
that I hate that so supposedly over in
Life pod seven there's a radiation suit
and then I can take it a life body but
there's no way there's gonna be anyone
else alive here
they're all dead a million ways from
Sunday they're all dead well it's even
more interesting about that is that I'm
being guided towards them so the
developers are starting to build some of
the story and answer some of the weird
ask questions as to number one
am I the only one here I hate it I hate
it
hi Sancho I see you in the distance over
there but I still hate it need air oh I
hate it radiation oh [ __ ]
well [ __ ] I can't even get to her life
pod seven well how am I gonna be able to
help them they're gonna die in the
radiation zones oh those poor sons of
[ __ ] that kinda is a terrible feeling
there's nothing that I could do this too
much radiation and if I could if I
couldn't survive how would they oh my
god that's a whole new way of even
thinking about this like this whole
endeavor of going into the ocean like
before it was just like oh god I'm alone
everyone else is dead I guess but now
everyone else isn't dead they're dying
and that's a horrible feeling I mean the
eventual goal I imagine at this game
would be to have some semblance of
multiplayer to this because otherwise
you're isolated stay on this world it's
going to be extremely lonely right
anyway do I have another message waiting
for me do I know just the fact that I
failed all right I'm gonna go start
building my base because as you guys
know I don't have the lockers so I can't
put names on them I'm a big bad doofy do
so in the kelp forest there are pieces
of the glider which it's not the UH it's
not the seamoth and it's gonna be a
while till I get the seamoth because I'm
not gonna cheat that's a hundred percent
correct I'm not even gonna be dive gonna
be sad about the fact that I'm not gonna
cheat it's gonna not do it what I need
to find is I need to find the sea glider
so I can Elise know it's way closer than
I thought it was
I hate being down here in the dark I
hate it I hate it I hate it hate it haha
[ __ ] yeah be light let there be light
okay let there be light goddamn it lob
me lob me good [ __ ] me good just like
you should okay I got some air so I got
we're getting the little first little
bleeding elements of daylight so what we
need to do is we need to find the sea
glider which now I mentioned the ball I
got there somebody yeah so means guy
what is that so the creature egg I don't
need that oh it's gross oh I think
that's a piece ah that's a piece but
he's right by it
ah Oh brave halusky okay yeah I got it
I'm out of here baby
oh I'm so out here alright so I got the
see Clyde see glad see glad
so I need battery lubricant copper wire
and titanium and I can do all those
things because I need acid mushroom for
the battery but I can make copper wire
if I get more copper or so I'm gonna put
I'm gonna put the titanium bursts on
hold I'm gonna go get some more copper
battery acid mushrooms [ __ ] going on
what else I need copper wire lubricant I
need a little bit of the honey so the
seed pods you know I'm talking about see
odds you're good ear okay now I need see
pods yeah but I need to be stealthy
about in with the app with the app good
thing they can't hear me shouting and
screaming underwater God that would be
my one weakness they would definitely
exploit uh-huh seed pods to grab them on
the way little bit about video give me
give me give me course yeah full after
three I need to get rid of that get rid
of that no don't eat that what were you
thinking you freak you freak what are
you thinking god damn it you weirdo we
gotta be like that eat a nutrient block
damn it why don't you eat that with you
but we got what we needed it oh we
forgot the copper but I'm out of space
so I might as well make the lose you I
got the lube all right let me go get the
capper
yeah what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude
did those things blow oh my god
Oh God holy [ __ ] what did you do to Gary
yeah that happened here creature egg my
god oh god it's the cave of Horrors I
hate this game I hate everything about
it not this one that I'm in right now
but the win over there I remember when I
first started playing this I saw that
cave and I was equally as scared as I am
right now and god dammit did I not know
what I'm doing but it still seemed to be
floundering just as much dope doc copper
where's my copper where's all the gap er
good copper yep yes okay that'll be off
that will be enough I have enough okay I
have more than enough which is good
because I'm planning for the future like
I should because I'm smile wicked smile
make two copper wire make the battery
year
take the C glide yes thank you very much
I needed that badly cuz it was going
slow inventory full load of dicks right
right right give yes see God will
increase your exploration range please
pack supplies for long journeys always
stay within five kilometres of veneers
life pod or habitat don't tell me what
to do you're not my dad you're not my
real dad
what another really this is Aurora life
pod six we've touched down within one
kilometer of the crash site but our path
to the rendezvous was irradiated we've
only got one rad suit requesting
immediate assistance coordinates
attached really where where where are
you oh it's this one yeah
where's life pod six dang it why are
they always so close to the irradiated
area
what are they dead and they did they're
dead aren't they okay I need fiber mesh
if I'm gonna be able to do that where do
I get fiber mesh again what made fiber
mesh I can make a radiation suit and I
should be able to do that but I need to
make any creepvine sample I can do that
I shouldn't have eaten that one of them
but I'm coming for you six there we go
okay I got two enough for a fireman
enough to make a radiation suit enough
to go get life pod six and see what the
[ __ ] is up because there is a story here
and I did not expect a story to be here
maybe you guys did but I'd certainly did
not yeah I can make the radiation suit
because I did get lag unfortunately I
did get LED so should be able to put
this on how about ski right am i wearing
them yes I am okay so I'm good to go I'm
coming for you six dawn meadow new five
fives coming for you baby they better
not be dead by the time I get here I
better not have been knocked out for
like 15 years but no if they sent the
message after the radiation started
leaking that would have been after the
explosion which means that they might be
alive or at least I might have been
close which I don't know if that's any
better I don't think that's better at
all I think that's in fact much worse to
know that I was almost there to save
them I almost had friends in this lonely
adventure and I
almost did what was right but instead I
[ __ ] around in the world in the ocean
it was scared of my own shadow but man
this is close right there holy [ __ ] it's
sunk which is not a good sign
didn't none of their flow tables work oh
man that's no good
that's not good oh that's the volcano of
God
damn it okay hello Oh No t plus four
minutes oh my god what the hell happened
how did this explode out of here that
doesn't make any sense
radiation gloves are there radiation
helmet all the radiation equipment is
here so I could have come over here and
gotten them but why did it explode
seriously why is this exploding here let
me see if was log data downloads
lifepods here we go oh man ma'am I need
you to stay calm we're not in immediate
danger where are the rescue teams the
ship didn't make it so where are the
rescue teams they're dead ma'am whip oh
oh wait oh I thought so I was nine I was
running out of air geez okay sorry about
that everybody so where are the rescue
teams they're dead man we have the
rendezvous coordinates but the route
there is heavily irradiated from the
crash site and we still only have one
rad suit so what are you gonna do if I
can take the suit perhaps I can find a
lead source in the area come back and
fabricate a second suit for you then we
can swim to the rendezvous how do I know
you'll not just save yourself give me
the suit I'll go do you know how to
properly equip I said I'll go that
doesn't sound good
that doesn't sound good at all and also
let me put my see glide down here I
don't know why I wasn't using it cuz big
dumb dummy all right man oh there's
another pot and there's another day too
bad in here data bad
oh boy t+ 27 minutes I should never let
her leave with that rad suit by now
she's either swum to dry land whoo we
will we will we will we by now she she's
either swum to dry land or drowned
trying meanwhile the air filters aren't
keeping up with the hull breach
radiation levels in the pot are rising
I won't last much longer without meds
this would be the time to take the easy
way out if all the options on the table
weren't equally horrific hatch opens
help me what happened I tried to make it
to the rendezvous but I started feeling
sick barely made it back this is
important if the suit breach are you
contaminated no I don't know what's
wrong did you set the air levels right
yes did you remember to do up the zipper
what zipper what zipper your radiation
levels shouldn't be this high ma'am
you've been exposed too ma'am ma'am wake
up if you could make it off this planet
please don't tell people I died because
I couldn't dress myself life signs
flatlined your secret's safe with me
I don't expect it make it off this
planet what the hell how long was I out
for why are all my messages delayed and
why why are these people dying around me
I've got another suit can I take the
Power Cells oh no oh no Lisa I know how
to do up my zipper so sad but I think I
can make it a life pod seven now whoo
yeah stare at that and use it good job
you here we go
oh we're skedaddle and look at us go in
the middle of the night I've been
gliding through the sea in the middle of
the night please don't eat me bad the
middle of the night in my pants I will
pee not let's do those dumb I'm sorry
about that
Oh all right I'm going to lifepod seven
but something tells me it's gonna be
equally as sad oh boy oh boy we're
reaching deeper waters and it's the
middle of the night and I don't like it
what's happening
what's going on there whoa what the [ __ ]
you've got an ecosystem on your back
dude whoa hey what the [ __ ] you're
gigantic
holy [ __ ] don't like that oh my god I'm
gonna scan you yeah I'm on scan you oh
[ __ ] you to you I'll reef back okay yeah
yeah I don't like you you're bigger than
you used to be in there more time with
the fire I don't wanna know I got it oh
they're much bigger than they used to be
that is way bigger they I think in this
update they made absolutely everything
in this place horrifying and deadly Oh
No
ah you're in a SAN shark infested area
well I'm gonna go get the things in here
then try to make it out of here quickly
because it can't huh but it's a can
quick as you can
[ __ ] was gummy what was that ow [ __ ]
give me my goddamn health kit good thing
I got this is there anything around here
that I should know about
okay okay Yee okay looking looking
looking looking looking looking I know I
know I know I know it's bad if the
situation bad ball come here in the day
and I'll look at the log later I hate
the [ __ ] ocean [ __ ] this ocean [ __ ]
everything about it god I would never
swim around here yeah even if I was by
myself I wouldn't go in the goddamn
ocean to try to survive it's probably
what happened to everybody else in the
other life pods like they were like they
took one look out the window they're
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] holy [ __ ] No
oh okay so I got the log I didn't see
anything else but then again I was in a
bit of a hurry because I was about to
die now that I got the thing what's in
here hello oh it's pretty yeah it was a
mistake it was a mistake I shouldn't
come in here why are they screaming at
me oh wow I'm glad that went through
okay that was does a detour that I
probably shouldn't have taken there bad
idea bad idea better
okay I'm back yeah it's me it's me
markiplier back again with a data log I
guess dammit how are we gonna find the
other others without a rendezvous signal
we have a bearing on where the other
pods went down this compass in the
locker we have options wait you just
want to swim for it are you serious
have to eventually if there's any rescue
coming it's months maybe years away we
find the others patch up Aurora's
long-range comms and set about building
a permanent habitat did you stop to pick
up your tools while you were running for
your life
no but the fabricator is not broken all
we need is some basic materials I'm
gonna go out there to see what I can
find and they didn't make it back
because they were in a more hostile area
than I was so that's my only Theory the
only reason that I survived is because
my pod
is like the only one that landed in the
safe zone every other zone was either
too close to the Aurora to survive the
radiation or in the depths where they
got eaten alive instantaneously that's a
horrifying thought my god but anyway I
guess we're doing pretty good so I got
the see glide I've got the I've got the
fabricator so in the next episode I'm
gonna actually get to building a base
and building up and trying to survive
here and get the rest of the stuff but
the story is moving forward here and I
still have C pod 8 to look for because
I'm gonna keep C pod 7 and C pod 8 here
cuz I needed to double-check C pod 7 but
life pod 8 is still a mystery but
chances are they're still dead right
okay
gonna be fun so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye thanks
for this [ __ ]
[Music]